[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je voyais dans bonjour bonjour voilà des
images assez impressionnantes d'un temps
qui fut glorieux qui était dans toute
l'histoire de france est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas le sentiment que ce temps est
un petit peu révolu beaucoup de chants
glosent sur l'indépendance de la france
en se disant que au fond pour être
indépendant fut d'abord fort que la
france ait pas si forte que ça et
notamment économiquement ce n'est jamais
qu'une moyenne puissance qu'est ce que
vous leur répondre se dépeint un temps
révolu
sur les deux siècles qui viennent d'être
rapidement un racontée à travers des
images rythme qui moi m'a plu voit jenny
chypre rien
cette composition mais j'ai admiré la
qualité de cette réalisation
si l'histoire de france ça l'a dit mais
on comprend quand même il ya débat ne
sommes pas dans un bas simplement les
rapports de force la population on la
rapporte démographique des rapports de
puissance aujourd'hui deux empires
américains soviétiques
tout cela fait que la france pourra
trouver des appuis tout en gardant ses
valeurs
il a trouvé l'europe et c'est la france
qui a pris l'initiative de l'europe
je continue et d'autre part sur le plan
économique elle nous avons été pris dans
une crise mondiale nous sommes pas ceux
qui en ont plus souffert mais nous avons
beaucoup souffert et j'ai le sentiment
que depuis un certain nombre d'années
je pose depuis quand sans quoi on va
dire non en tout cas depuis 7 8 10 ans
on a pris véritablement les les autres
la volonté de réussir et eu des échecs
et des réussites mais je crois que la
france pas tous les moyens de gagner
cette bataille en a quand même le
sentiment qu'elle n'a pas la place de
naguère et qu'elle n'est pas le moteur
d'une part la situation hélas pas la
situation d'après austerlitz hélas pas
la situation de du premier louis xiv
certes mais elle a une situation
aujourd'hui encore plein de grandeur de
rayonnement et pour ses 55 millions
d'habitants par rapport aux grandes
masses qui pèsent sur le monde
quand on pense que la france est le
troisième pays du monde sur le plan de
l'organisation militaire le quatrième et
le cinquième sur le plan industriel et
sur le plan de ses exportations sur car
économique
c'est quand même pas mal alors il ya des
chutes il ya dix ratage
il ya des politiques plus ou moins bonne
le sujet mais le filet où il savait mais
c'est pas le sujet
l'instant est sous total la france a
toutes les raisons de croire en elle
même mais il faut qu'elles s'appuient
qu'elle travaille avec les autres
européens qui ont accompli la même
évolution
alors ces thèmes de politique étrangère
que on a choisi de le décliner
aujourd'hui on va le on va les découvrir
tout d'abord à travers un clip réalisé
par mathias le doubs sur les grands
thèmes force de la france aujourd'hui de
sa politique étrangère
[Musique]
vous
la france a besoin d'un président qui
décide en matière de politique étrangère
la position de la france dans le monde
et en matière de défense il faut que la
guerre demeure impossible et que ceux
qui songerait en soit dissuasif
[Musique]
nous devons veiller toujours à respecter
la souveraineté n'est pas sur ses
affaires intérieures mais le droit n'a
pas de frontières dès lors qu'il s'agit
de bien universels dont la liberté de
vivre de penser d'agir et de venir est
le fondement
[Musique]
et paie on a bien compris le message
alors sans sauter sur sa chaise comme un
cabri comme le faisait le général de
gaulle quand il parlait il entendait
parler d'europe
on a envie de se dire fils un mort au
fond tous les candidats parlent de paix
mais qui a pacifisme et pacifisme et
certains peuvent vous accusez d'un
pacifisme naïve ou fait trop confiants
dit on parfois aux soviétiques après cet
accord de désarmement très important
entre ronald reagan et mikhaïl
gorbatchev le problème n'est pas de
savoir si nous sommes pour la paix les
uns les autres
elle a entendu nous sommes pour la paix
le problème est de savoir si on en prend
le chemin
posez-moi des questions quand je vous le
dit par exemple on fait confiance à
monsieur gorbatchev
non c'est simplement j'ai confiance en
nous c'est toute la différence et le
sentiment ambiant sans moi que l'europe
ait pas trop dégarni que la france n'est
pas trop dégarni en quoi le serait-elle
après cet accord messieurs vous savez
que l'accord de washington entre riga
légaux bachelot ne vise absolument pas
l'armement de la france ni l'armement
nucléaire de la grande bretagne
c'est un accord entre russes et
américains et le fait que les russes et
les américains décident de réduire un
peu moins de 10% leur formidable arsenal
nucléaire
moi je trouve cela très bon c'est le
chemin du désarmement donc c'est le
chemin de la paix on peut craindre une
sorte de d'abandon de l'europe
alors là c'est un problème qui va
beaucoup plus loin
savoir si en vérité l'alliance
atlantique
l'alliance entre les américains les
européens tient bon et de ce point de
vue il n'y a pas de raison nouvelle en
tout cas de poser le problème autrement
qu'il a été posé il ya déjà 20 ans quant
à la relation avec l'union soviétique
nous sommes sur le même continent nous
sommes à braives distance et quand je
vois le gouvernement soviétique et
monsieur gorbatchev s'orienter il a ses
raisons
ce sont sans doute pas exactement les
mêmes que les nôtres aller vers une
réduction de sa puissance militaire
je ne peux que m'en réjouir et je ne
comprends pas ce qui
tout en donnant leur accord verbal
constamment retardé l'échéance
quels risques avons-nous pris depuis le
premier jour de mon élection j'ai veillé
à maintenir notre force vraiment en
situation comme on dit donc fini bilité
c'est à dire que les autres puissances
et notamment l'union soviétique sache
que il ne peut pas y avoir de guerre
parce que le risque est trop grand et
compris pour l'union soviétique
c'est ce qu'on appelle la dissuasion
nucléaire et c'est l'essentiel de notre
doctrine je m'y tiens nous avons un sous
marin nucléaire de plus nous allons en
avoir après les années 90 encore un
autre
je ne cherche pas à forcer les choses je
veux que la france reste en situation de
sécurité mais cela ne m'empêche pas de
plaider partouche sur toutes les
tribunes internationales estime âme pour
le désarmement je suis allé dire aux
nations unies que si les deux grands
empires union soviétique états unis
d'amérique diminuait leurs armes au
point d'atteindre une proportion
considérable
ils ont 13 mai la 11000 charges
nucléaires
une stratégie que nous allons aux
environs de 300 faut qu'ils fassent un
effort colossal avant que nous puissions
nous mettre autour de la table
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire étant
entendu que la france en attendant le
moment où le désarmement sera
suffisamment important pour qu'ils nous
concerne une baisse pas la garde elle
est là elle est présente et elle peut
continuer à moderniser son armement
money and julio garde de l'otan un
problème très sensible et continue
naturellement a modernisé son armement
son armement stratégique
le problème qui s'est posé récemment
c'était la question de savoir si au
moment où l'on est en train de faire
disparaître du centre de l'europe
les armes nucléaires dites
intermédiaires marc intermédiaire ça
veut dire celles qui vont d'un bout à
l'autre de l'europe donc qu'ils peuvent
nous détruire comme elles peuvent
détruire n'importe quel autre pays
d'europe traverse pas la tenter elles
font entre 500 et 5500 km l'accord de
washington c'est ça on s'en débarrasse
on les élimine partir de là il reste des
armes nucléaires aude saut entre 0 et 5
100 km les premiers gestes certains
c'est à dire bien on va les renforcer
non au moment où dont un mort sur le
désarmement
posons des conditions qu'elles à
condition que je pose que j'ai pose à
l'union soviétique et qui a été adoptée
approuvé par la réunion de l'otan'' qui
s'est tenu à bruxelles nous en avons
parlé tous les deux ça a été de dire
bien
le premier geste utile en europe c'est
que les soviétiques diminue leur
puissance militaire classique
conventionnelle avions chars canons
toute force qu'ils ont infiniment plus
puissantes que celles des pays de
l'ouest aux frontières d allemagne
d'apcher cosnac alors ça il faut qu'il
démontre leur bonne volonté
il faut leur donner un délai il faut
leur dire écoutez si dans les deux ans
qui viennent vous n'avez pas engager la
négociation sur ces armes
conventionnelles ou nous sommes là nous
risquons d'être en situation de
faiblesse
eh bien nous renforcerons le reste de
notre arsenal
vous savez il ya aussi un autre débat
qui s'est engagé dans ce pays à ce
propos il ya des gens qui disent il ya
beaucoup trop d'argent
donner au surarmement et cet argent on
ferait mieux de donner aux pays en voie
de développement
parce que le prochain conflit à venir
sera peut-être pas est-ouest
mais ce sera nord-sud c'est un
raisonnement tout à fait juste on
n'imagine pas les sommes perdues
dissiper sont véritablement de plants
sains productive
on parle de croissance et donc de
développement de l'emploi alors que l'on
gèle des milliards et des milliards de
dollars de frein de toutes les monnaies
il faut éviter le surarmement et
pourquoi j'approuve son contraire qui
est la mort ce le début d'abord ceux de
désarmement
c'est le premier désarmement depuis la
fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale c'est
très important alors nous avons déjà
proposé aux nations unies monsieur
giscard d'estaing l'a fait avant moi je
les fais moi si monsieur edgar faure
était allé plaider la même cause
toujours sur la même tribune en disant
développons un plan qui permettrait
chaque fois que l'on désarmerait surtout
sur le plan nucléaire de consacrer une
partie des sommes économisées au
développement du tiers monde peut-être
une vue un peu idéale et l'a retenu
l'attention
je crois qu'elle trouvera un jour une
réponse mais bien entendu le problème du
tiers monde ne tient pas qu'à cela ce
qui est vrai vous avez vous l'avez dit
c'est que les menaces qui pèsent sur la
sécurité dans le monde à cause du
déséquilibre entre les pays riches et
les pays pauvres
c'est une menace aussi inquiétante que
peut l'être l'armement nucléaire
demain c'est 1989 1989 il ya tout juste
deux siècles grand message de la france
et est liberté égalité fraternité
là vous avez une poignée de secondes
pour nous dire ce que vous souhaiteriez
pour la france comme message demain dans
le monde entier bien précisément le
message de paix liberté égalité
fraternité c'est toujours actuel fait au
moment où le monde sont dressés où
partout surgissent des conflits locaux
régionaux ou l'on voit la haine et le
sans dire le mot paix et en prendre le
chemin
c'est un grand message je crois monsieur
prise un jour mars
je vous remercie également dire le mot
paix et en prendre le chemin
c'est un drame et ça
[Musique]